well firstly yeah the grain situation is
a brand new perspective on the war here
and um given that 90 of the World's
Trade moves by the oceans it shows the
vital importance of the ports for Putin
um one question of course having seen
the report why don't they move this
grain by land well if you look at the 25
million tons of grain that will be
around 1 million trucks worth so it's
just not practical and that highlights
the importance of why Vladimir Putin
wants to take all of the ports and
therefore we'll have a view on Odessa in
the in the future now clearly at the
moment he's gone as far as Kirsten which
is just to the east of Odessa there but
over the recent weeks um a Ukrainian
forces have mounted several
counter-attacks in the area and so
whilst Putin isn't ready to take Odessa
yet he's much too focused up here he
doesn't want to lose Kirsten and that's
why we're seeing reinforcements of the
positions there not for now but for
Downstream so he can actually finally
take the port of Odessa Downstream well
you mentioned these let's move away from
Odessa up to Don bass what's going on
there at the moment well it's Fierce
fighting
I'm here and I've we've watched it many
times it we keep saying Fierce fighting
I've had a look back at sort of three
weeks ago where the maps and the
positions were they haven't actually
changed a great deal but what has
changed is that the the Russian Focus
now the intensity of the a war they've
actually finally put a military Focus to
that they've got clear objectives and
that is clearly luhansk falling first
then Donetsk and they're trying to do
that in a much more militaristic way now
in bite-sized portions the first part of
that is Sever Donetsk which is the main
focus of the fighting at the moment and
you can almost see here the sort of
fingers of or the Jaws as they're trying
to encircle separate Nets around there
the Gap there is about 25 kilometers and
what Russia will be seeking to do is to
seal off the city uh stop the lines of
communication all of the supplies for
the um Ukrainian forces and then resort
to the sort of um medieval bloodthirsty
um devastating a war of attrition which
they've done before which is incredibly
costly but it seems to be the only way
that they can secure Putin's desire to
see some form of progress
adult sounds very Bleak can you can
anything positive
positive the problem is um so on the we
don't know what Russian morale's like at
the moment from the troops wise but they
are certainly getting through equipment
and people at a tremendous rate and most
western analysts believe that the the
attrition of the Russian forces is just
not sustainable and they will have to
have some sort of operational pause at
some stage looking at this though one of
the options is that Putin does indeed
take the Don bass and if he does that
the question is can he hold it because
by that stage he will be it's quite a
big area massively stretched his troops
and they'll all be utterly exhausted
we've got Western Aid party into the
country and that will be an ideal time
for the ukrainians to mount a fierce
counter-attack
um the other thing is they just grind to
a halt and that's distinctly possible as
well at which point Russia would
probably Annex the areas that it's
already taken and prepare itself for a
surge in the future and of course all of
that describes the fact that Ukraine
does have a vote president zielinski
does have a vote in all of this and
every time Russia extends itself
Ukrainian creates opportunities for a
counter-tank but let's be blunt here
Russia has the momentum at the moment